all right everybody will welcome to the
fourth rational physics conference my
name is Dave Robinson
one quick announcement before we begin
one of the proponents of the rational
scientific method that goes by the
moniker monkey mind has written some
books and so if you're interested in
them you can buy them back there after
the conference whenever so and just so
you guys know all the proceeds are going
to the free Ross campaign and I got a
chance to speak to Lynn briefly and she
was really really thankful so thank you
for coming and thank you to the speakers
for coming here the forth rational
physics conference is a continuation of
a conference that happens in Europe and
the purpose of the conference is to give
people who have criticisms of the
mainstream or theories of their own the
chance to share those ideas before an
audience and the conference has been put
on by Bill Gates every year and if you
don't know who Bill Gates is he is a
critic of relativity quantum mechanics
and string theory and he has his own
theory called thread theory when I first
came across thread theory about four or
five years ago I thought it was
interesting but I didn't really
understand it until I dug in and read
the book several times and at this point
I think I'm pretty confident I can say
that this is one of the most significant
scientific discoveries in a long time I
think it's a really big deal and people
oftentimes say well where's all his
peer-reviewed papers you know where's
his Nobel Prize and so on and so forth
and you've tried to publish papers but
you've been sort of ostracized turned
away stonewalled you know called the
crank and a crackpot a few times here
and there and a while back in one of the
Facebook groups we were kind of
discussing this and discussing maybe the
futility of trying to spread these ideas
and you have some other ideas which
don't bode well for the future of man
and so I had to ask you what's the point
of putting on these conferences you know
why do this why are you came all the way
out from Germany why come all the way
out here and I thought your answer was
really pretty inspiring he said look
Dave the only reason that I'm coming all
the way out to a narco
wilco is to drink beer so what that mean
said this one's for you bill ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Bill Gates I
was gonna give up introduction but I
guess he beat me to it
Dave so I don't need to explain much of
that the only thing I want to add to
what he said is that the rational
physics rational science group
criticizes the establishment but what do
we criticize we criticize that the
mathematics of it we say that
mathematics first has nothing to do with
physics mathematics has nothing to do
with science science is about explaining
not about describing math is a
descriptive language it can only
describe I can tell you how fast
something running I can tell you how
fast what the acceleration of gravity is
but I cannot explain to you what gravity
is or how it does it's magic for this
there's only one way you have to try to
figure out what invisible object is
doing the mechanism and that's what I'm
gonna explain today I'm gonna do it with
black holes I chose the black hole
because the black hole is like the the
ingrown toenail the smoking gun of
relativity it's as irrational as it can
get if you can't get past the
irrationality of a black hole
I'm wasting my time today I should pack
my bags and leave if I can't make my
case today with a black hole I gotta
leave I have nothing more to offer okay
I called my presentation the rope
hypothesis rationally explains Dark
Matter black hole and big bang and I'm
gonna go through four steps here the
first one is I'm gonna argue that there
is no such thing as a black hole you
read about black hole every week that
they discovered one that they saw one
that they prove that whatever and
I'm gonna argue that there's no such
thing as a black hole why because you
heard of impossible objects can you get
the tribe are you can't produce this in
three dimensions you've got the Penrose
staircase that the the impossible cube
you have all these things which are
known as impossible objects there are
irrational
objects and that's where the black hole
book belongs it's an irrational object
okay that's what I'm going to show today
then I'm gonna go in there and explain
phenomena that currently is attributed
to black holes and I'm gonna give you a
totally different scenario you're gonna
see with your own eyes a different
perspective
now I haven't come here to convince
anyone I haven't come here to persuade
or recruit anyone I just want to give
you something that you can compare and
make your own decision that's the way
science should work we should not just
shove down your throats a theory and say
it's been proven we have the truth no I
explain you understand we're done with
science what continues now is religion
I'm gonna explain phenomena attributed
to black holes then I'm going to explain
a phenomenon attributed to dark matter
as well and finally I'm going to argue
against another icon of relativity which
is the Big Bang I'm saying it never
happened there was no beginning to our
universe okay so on with the first one
there's no such thing as a black hole
what is a black hole what is the
definition of a black hole when you look
up the this term what are they talking
about that's the first one I'm gonna go
through and I'm gonna go through how
many dimensions a black hole has we're
gonna find out the black hole has many
dimensions what is a black hole made of
I think it's a rational question that
ask if it's a physical object what does
it made out of
have we ever discovered a black hole
have you ever seen when have we ever
proven black holes and I'm gonna get
testimonies official testimonies on that
and finally if we have not proven the
black hole then we have to conclude that
maybe the black hole is beyond human
understanding and we have to accept it
like we accept other religious things on
the basis of faith Authority or
whichever one you want okay so I'm with
a person what is a black hole well when
you do some research where you like
research you find out that the black
hole has essentially two definitions
there's two notions of a black hole
under one hand you have the black ball
and on the other one you have a region
of space or of space-time so you have
these two notions we have NASA treats it
like an object as a black ball and
here's the testimony this is this is
directly from these web sites right
black hole a great amount of matter
packed into a very small area they're
talking about small non zero dimensional
talking about small think of a star ten
times more massive than the Sun squeezed
into a sphere they're talking about a
sphere and I talking about zero
dimensional approximately the diameter
of New York City diameter again
something right greater than zero
gravity is so strong because matter has
been squeezed into a tiny space again
all the representations you're talking
about something there's something that
has size diameter they're talking about
black ball okay
wolfram physics treats it as an object
space com2 two 9s they're only
relatively small you see it there and
city size range so again they're all
talking about something a little ball of
some kind
the star shrinks and turns into a ball
not into nothing but into a ball and
then we have the other side where they
treat as a concept the region region of
space or of space-time depending on who
you talk to and Berkeley says it's a
region of space but the good one comes
from Max Planck Institute says a black
hole is not a tangible object making it
clear you're now talking about a ball
you're not talking about tangible object
but it's a region of space and says
later on says black holes themselves are
not solid objects they miss but they
said object okay it's not a solid object
there's nothing there okay so we have
these two notions now there's a
difference between a ball in your region
now I know some of you were not from
this planet you know so I'm gonna show
you something that is from our planet
our planet is Earth and this is the
mysterious black ball okay now black
ball can you all see this yes why can
you see it you can see it because you
have light reflecting to your eyes or if
the ball is emitting light to your eyes
some signal and you capture it with your
eyes you see it but before you can do
that there's got to be a precondition
and the precondition is the black ball
has to have shape if there's no shape
here there's nothing to reflect light to
you there's nothing for it to emit
because there's nothing here but here
you can see it now this is a region of
space you can see it here and between my
two fingers in fact I'll take my fingers
out so you can see it better
do you see anything yeah how can a
region of space send you any signal see
no reason of space is not a physical
object it's not the same thing as a ball
so these people have two different
notions and I synthesized it here what
does a region look like have you ever
seen a region can't bring the region to
you like I brought the ball I can bring
a chair I can bring you a table tree a
rock I can't bring you a region because
the region is always of something else I
can talk to you about the region of the
ball but I can't talk to you about
region just itself in fact I could do
something else I can
I can show you my hand I cut my hand off
of the wrist
I can show you my hand and I can talk to
you about the palm the palm is a region
of the hand I can talk oh so about a
palm but I have to cut the fingers so I
cut the fingers off I show you the palm
say this is a palm so far so good but if
I want to talk to you about the palm
being a region of the hand I got to so
the fingers back on because a region is
always of something else and now you
have the very funny conclusion because
of this these two these two notions
region versus ball we're and we're in
Mexico let's use a Mexican citizen we
take a Mexican citizen from the streets
we crush them we smash them we make them
as small as possible and we turn them
into a region of Mexico sounds like a
plan
that's what they're doing they're taking
a star their shrinking is here's a
standalone object and they're convenient
Verta get into a region of space-time
what sense does that make
right there they have first a
contradiction in the definitions and
second they draw these conclusions that
a standalone object becomes a region of
something else it makes no sense
whatsoever okay how many dimensions does
a black hole have well one of the
persons who most worked on black holes
originally was Chandra Sekhar he was an
Indian student who went to Great Britain
and he became famous eventually got the
Nobel Prize because of his work on black
holes
this was Chandrasekhar said there is a
limit to the repulsion that the
exclusion principle can provide when the
star got sufficiently dense the
repulsion caused by the exclusion
principle would be less than the
attraction of gravity friend Rajendra
Secor calculated that a cold star more
than about one and a half times the mass
of the Sun would not be able to support
itself against its own gravity it would
collapse completely Eddington who was
his boss nixed that he said no I'm gonna
let you continue in this line of work
you thought it was simply not possible
that a star could collapse to a point
and this was the view of most scientists
in those days and Einstein himself wrote
a paper in which he claimed that stars
would not strength to zero size and then
Chandrasekhar wins the Nobel Prize and
he had shown that the exclusion
principle could not halt the collapse of
a star more massive than the
Chandrasekhar limit and that's in a
brief history of time by Stephen Hawking
so this is official this is the this is
the current thought so here we have a
star collapses to nothing to zero
dimensions okay here we have the BBC
they made a documentary in which another
rising star a Brian Green says something
different he says the black holes are
collapsed stars massive objects crushed
to a fraction of their original size now
this is not zero dimensional now they're
talking about fraction and size so again
we have these two versions which is
correct our does a star collapse all the
way or does it does it remain as a ball
at the end so he's representing the
black ball whereas the testimony just
now by Stephen Hawking is that it's it's
it's nothing it's zero dimensional so we
have zero dimension on three diamonds so
someone asked the question how many
dimensions does a singularity could have
and several of the mathematicians not
physicists gave answers I picked out two
because they address two separate issues
the first one said the concept of a
singularity is a mathematical concept
not a physics concept and this is funny
because we have constantly in fact I
think it have it here and the string
theory says are very clearly the
language of physics is mathematics so
it's the language of physics is
mathematics here they're saying
something different they're saying the
concept of the singularity belongs to
mathematics it does not belong to
physics so we have a contradiction they
go around in circles you say well how
many dimensions there's a black hole how
they said X you say well but that's
mathematics yeah it's mathematics got
nothing to do with physics and then they
tell the astronomers go look for it now
they're looking for something in the sky
what do you look for if if this is a
mathematical concept we have these
contradictions constantly over
/ and a second answer which I picked
that says if we think just in terms of
space its zero dimensional but in a
spacetime it is one dimensional because
it exists over a period of time so now
you're saying hold it black hole
collapses to a zero dimensional point
nothing right and that's what you get on
the 3d space side right head-on view you
see nothing zero damage so what are you
gonna see but then if you see this in
time and you see a movie this zero
dimensional point traces a
one-dimensional line which comes out of
the other side in another universe as
the zero dimensional entrance now how
many of you try to enter a zero
dimensional entrance ever in your life
have you ever tried to crawl through a
one-dimensional line
this belongs totally in mathematics what
does this have to do with physics it has
nothing to do with physics but they go
around and around and around how many
dimensions does a black hole has I can
tell you right now it has zero
dimensional if you're talking about
space right right there it says so it
has one dimension if you talk about
space-time it has two dimensions if you
take a ball and squeeze it down to a
like if you project it onto a
two-dimensional platform and it has
three dimensions if you're gonna look
for it for it with your telescope so how
many diamonds it has it has zero one two
and three there's your answer
they covered every base Lewis Leonard
and Franz Pretorius these guys publish
the paper saying we showed this is a
peer-reviewed paper this is official the
black hole's radius is zero very clear
there's no radius there's nothing there
that's not what they draw look what they
drew they talked about I hope all of you
can see that black dot in the center
that's 2-dimensional at least it's got
width and height and and that's a
representation of a three-dimensional
ball so we have three dimensions two
dimensions and these guys are telling
you it's zero dimensional so which is
and and that's just the dot in the
center if you talk about the event
horizon which is the so-called limit the
region of influence of a black hole now
you're talking about at least 2d and 3d
so what they draw physics has nothing to
do with what they publish which is math
a published math and then they talked
and then they draw or illustrate physics
two different things and then again
someone here says the radius of a event
horizon increases as the mass of the
black hole increases now we're talking
about radius we're talking about size
again so they go back and forth so
what's the problem with all this well
the problem is that in physics when they
want to talk physics when they want the
common man who doesn't know anything
about mathematics what these guys are
refer you to they say look that's a
black hole and everybody can relate to
him he says yeah I understand what
they've got there it's some kind of
tornado and it's swallow stuff yeah I
understand perfectly well but that's not
what they publish this is what they
publish when you look at the papers that
they published in the peer-reviewed
journals they talk about zero
dimensionality they put their equations
there has nothing to do with what they
show the public so we don't know how
many dimensions have but in fact we do
they have zero one two and three because
they covered every base you can you
can't challenge this any more
what are black holes made of that
question was asked of these four gurus
of physics I call mathematicians because
they do everything with magic Michio
Kaku he just shrugged
Larry Krauss also shrugged he didn't
know and East Rominger he's from Harvard
professor from Harvard says ok already
you've asked me a question I can't
answer and max Terra or another rising
star so we don't really know what's
going on these were the official
responses now there's there's a problem
here because these are college
professors these guys studied at least
10 years in the Universities they have
PhDs ok and now they tell you well we
don't know what a whole black hole is
made up what do you mean you don't know
what a black hole is made oh let me show
you what a black hole is made of black
hole is a region of space that has much
mass concentrated in it black hole is
all mass and no body it's very simple
black hole has mass why didn't they
answer that question they should have
said oops made out of mass and then
maybe they opened up a can of worms if
they said that because if they say look
it's made out of mass and you say well
what do you mean it's made out of mass
well what really is that and here's the
problem the note here theorem says all
black hole solutions can be completely
characterized by only three
parameters mass electric charge and
angular momentum and the Wikipedia
clarifies that the simplest static black
holes have mass but neither electric
charge nor angular momentum so no matter
what black hole you deal with it has
mass some have angular momentum and
charge some don't but all of them have
mass why didn't they answer that
question these [ __ ] professors I'll tell
you why
mass is the quantity of matter of an
object or it's a measure of the quantity
of matter that's what you learn in high
school or college but the black hole's
crush matter out of existence there is
no matter in a black hole which is the
definition of mass the quantity of
matter so we have a circular definition
we have a black hole is made out of mass
mass is the quantity of matter but a
black hole crushes matter out of
existence so what do we have in the end
we ended up where we started zero we
have nothing so what do we have do we
have a ball do we have zero dimensions
singularity are we talking physics are
we talking math this is the problem but
if you think that's the end of it now
there's one more step here are these
other two gurus John Wheeler and Edwin
Taylor nature does not offer us any
concept as the amount of matter
history has trucked down every proposal
to define such a term even if we could
count the number of atoms or by any
other counting method try to evaluate
amount of matter that number would not
equal mass mass is not the quantity of
matter they have no clue what mass is
they don't have a definition so after we
went around in circles we find out that
mass is really not the quantity of
matter so we have several problems here
we have first two definitions we have
the region and the ball then we don't
know how many dimensions it had in fact
has all the dimensions because they
covered every base what are you talking
about you talking about space out eyes
got one dimension oh you're talking
about space now it's zero damage so you
don't know what are they talking about
and then they say you know they go
around the circles and tell you that you
know a black hole is made out of mass
masses the quantity of matter matters
crushed out of existence what have we
learned what is a black hole this is the
rationality of
and they put it out as proof okay let's
find out proof how do we stand on proof
have you ever seen a black hole they ask
these same people they say no no I
caught him in a moment they say no no
one has ever seen a black hole directly
so how do they prove it
I mean it's proven it's a fact we see it
every day in in the popularization
magazines
and now they're telling you we've never
seen a black hole well hold it just 10
days ago 10 days ago what an 11th of
February big news
we had the LIGO some people caught in
legal LIGO they this is a group that for
many years is the 1990s they've been
looking for gravitational waves they
finally found two black holes that came
together and that admitted the
gravitational waves are we proven it
well we proven it we're the first these
observations demonstrate the existence
of binary stellar black mass black hole
systems this is the first observation of
a binary black hole merger and
immediately someone in the Wikipedia put
it o 11th of February 2016 the first
ever direct detection of black holes was
announced by the LIGO collaboration well
these people are a touch we've we've
been proving black holes at least since
1988 and I brought proof this is from
Stephen Hawking's book a brief history
of time 1988 I have done a lot of work
on black holes and it would all be
wasted if it turned out that black holes
do not exist very powerful reasons for
making them exist in fact had a bet with
another college professor his name is
Kip Thorne and he said look if Cygnus x1
turns out to be a black hole I'm gonna
buy you what was it one year
subscription to Penthouse magazine and
he finally said I had to concede the bet
because all the evidence shows that
Cygnus x1 is a black hole what else
could it be
and he adds we also now have evidence
for several other black holes in system
like Cygnus x1 in our galaxy in in two
neighboring galaxies called a mag
aligning clouds so they have all this
evidence and now they say oh we've
discovered it for the first time
we've been discovering for a long time
in fact I'll show you more evidence
physics world this is 2011 famous black
hole confirmed after 40 years another
one this is 2012 January 2012 the very
first black hole ever discovered was
discovered at U of T November 2012
scientists baffled by huge by cold
discovered in tiny gauss leap they've
been discovering black holes every month
the first one always the first one
monster black hole's spin revealed for
first time so what are these people
talking about what do you mean the first
one they had to give jobs to LIGO
because these people hadn't discovered
anything in 25 years they spent 600
million dollars they didn't discover
anything and now at the 100th year
anniversary of Einstein they said we
finally discovered gravitational waves
and everybody pulled out the champagne
bottles among them Stephen Hawking he he
was given an interview he gave an
interview and he said oh this is a great
fine we finally discovered black holes
what do you mean you've always
discovered black holes and how can he
say he discovered black holes if he's
never seen one but has Stephen Hawking
looked through the scope and seen
something no someone else did
so he's taking their testimony and
putting it as his he's not an expert
witness in this he's never seen a black
hole in his life why should I trust his
word has he ever seen one can he bring
me a black hole can he draw a black hole
zero-dimensional senior Larry he's never
seen a black hole so he's not an expert
witness an astronomer might be able to
tell me yeah I've seen one okay but not
Stephen Hawking what are they doing
they're using his authority to convince
you the part oh if Stephen Hawking says
so it's it's law he's not an expert
witness in this trial he should be
called to trial so they ask the
astrophysicists at NASA who was the
first person to discover a black hole
and answer black holes cannot be
observed directly and therefore cannot
be discovered they only look at it
through indirect evidence what does this
mean it means they're not proving
anything they're making an assumption
let's say let's assume there's a black
hole that black holes exist we see
something what could cause it it must be
a black
that's an assumption that's not a proof
and they're turning their assumptions
and approves into facts that's what
they're doing here what to convince the
public to say look we know what we're
doing but they can't define it they
can't tell you how many dimensions that
but they've seen in they proven it we
got a problem
there's a contradiction there it's a
logical contradiction and here they tell
you how they discover black holes and
again it shows you that it's done
indirectly the way astronomers and
astrophysicists in astronomical
observations is to look for light from
ionized dust and gas being sucked into
something so fast that it could only be
a black hole again it's an assumption
which they're turning into fact but now
I got a problem with this what do you
mean dust being sucked in and I get the
light how can I get the light if it's
sucked in I thought a black hole was
black because it's stuck in everything
in its vicinity and nothing was able to
reach my eyes so we had a problem how
did they do this well it turns out that
when when they came out with this
Chandrasekhar limit they said look you
know black hole swallows everything in
its zero dimensions for the astronomer
said well we're out of a job what do we
look for and say we gotta get these guys
something to do or they're all gonna
know we're gonna set all the
observatories down so they came up with
Hawking radiation
what is Hawking radiation this is a
quantum mechanics mechanism vacuum
fluctuations caused a particle
antiparticle pair to appear close to the
event horizon of a black hole one of the
pair falls into the black hole while the
other escapes to an outside observer it
would appear that the black hole has
just emitted a particle so we have to
understand what they're saying here
they're saying space is made out of
particles you take a particle and an
anti particle you put them together and
you end up with nothing take a ball a
black ball on a white ball you'll put
them together and you end up with no
ball that's what they're saying
okay that's space space can do the
opposite it can break apart the two and
you have a particle and an anti particle
a white ball in this case a blue ball
and a red ball right the
new ball falls in it doesn't matter
which could be the anti particle or the
particle why does the red ball leave
what what allows the the red ball to
leave if this area here is all full of
gravity pointing to the center of the
black hole these people are saying in
other words gravity stops at the event
horizon if you stand at the edge of the
event horizon you won't be sucked in
you're out of the gravity's range if you
take a step over you get sucked into the
singularity but as long as you don't
step over that line you're okay
that's nonsense any star has an infinite
radius to use that term for gravity the
earth pulls on the moon a little outside
our atmosphere imagine if you were just
standing out our atmosphere and say well
fortunately you know gravity doesn't
affect me because I'm outside the range
of gravity that's what they're saying
they're saying that the red ball can
escape because there's no gravity there
and so we can just drift away
that's nonsense it should fall also into
the black hole there should be any
radiation coming out of black hole but
otherwise but if they did that all the
astronomers would be out of a job so
they had to create this nonsense called
Hawking radiation and now they look for
these sparks out there this is a Hawking
represented in his book you can see the
anti particle escaping to infinity but
gravity is not to infinity just the
particle escapes to infinity right this
is what they observe they observe gases
being sucked into something or nothing
whatever you want to look at it so the
gases of a star are sucked in somehow
and they said well it's gotta be that
black hole it's got to be something
there that's pulling it in all this mass
runaway gravity it's pulling all that
gases okay we all understand it we say
okay sounds reasonable
okay what else did they observe you
observe a star going around nothing in
circles there was a telescope they they
take measurements they say this storm is
moving quite fast it's moving around
nothing we don't see anything in there
now it could be you know some other
object that we can't see but they say
now it's got to be a black hole because
of the mass and you know it's just this
the star just goes around it and so
there you go straighten it like that
they say that's what's happening
they're putting a filling in the blanks
are saying that black hole I'm gonna put
it in there so you can see why that
stars going around well but it's an
assumption it's an assumption based on
the fact that black holes might exist
there could be something called a black
hole I can just put an angel that's what
I like to do I like angels you know
they're moving the star around and here
I have an angel sucking all the area in
there I mean yeah I can put anything
it's an assumption have I proven angels
know to know sometimes it let us assume
there are angels and if you concede my
assumption that I explained to you
anything and that's what they're doing
with a black hole so what are the
conclusions well it's an irrational
entity first because again we don't know
how many dimension it has we don't know
if it's a black ball or a region we
don't know what mass is they have never
defined the word mass people will argue
for centuries with me mass and weight
are exactly the same thing and when I
say that people get so offended at me
but they've never been able to isolate
mass from weight why because we measure
them in the same way you want to measure
mass in fact that's that's where we had
the yeah the master is kept of the
kilogram is kept in Paris and it's a
chunk of metal that weighs one kilogram
and we say that's one kilogram of mass
how do you know that weighs when did you
count all the atoms in there is it the
quantity of matter
no they waited they said this is gonna
be the kilogram so weight and mass are
the same thing because they have never
been able to isolate one from the other
they don't count atoms they don't count
particles of matter they measure and
when you measure when you weigh or
whatever do you're not you you know then
you can't distinguish mass from weight
and so these people have no definition
for for mass and no one has ever seen a
black hole but if you read any
popularization of the black hole you
will find always the same thing they've
proven it it's a done deal
nothing to argue and this is this what
should make you stop and think that
something is wrong with mathematical
physics ok so this is what we got to
answer we have a star going around
something or nothing we have to answer
what's happening here this
real thing that they're observing in the
sky we got a if it's not a black hole
and it's not angels what is it we got to
answer this question scientists can't
avoid it and the same thing here if if
gas is being sucked into nothing how do
we explain this what's what's going on
out there in the sky in the night sky so
that's what I'm gonna answer now I'm
gonna give you something again I haven't
come here to convince anyone came here
just to give you an alternative so you
can choose make up your own minds okay
when you're in high school you're taught
that the light is an electromagnetic
wave okay what is a wave well according
to Niels Bohr early part of the century
of the 20th century he said the electron
jumps back and forth from the different
energy levels it drops to a lower energy
level and emits in quantum energy and
when it rises it absorbs a quantum of
energy so that's what you're seeing here
that's the quantum leap their quantum
jump and when it falls to an energy
level it's a wave it it's a quantum of
energy and that's the wave that you see
running out there it's the
electromagnetic wave and it's made out
of an electric field and a magnetic
field at 90 degrees to each other okay
what are the problems with us with a set
up do with this thing that they teach us
in high school there's no such thing as
a wave wave is with something does a
flag waves but I can't say a wave waves
wave is what something does you can say
the water wave but you can't say the
wave waves what's the object that's
waving well they tell you there is no
object in the case of light and some
people say well it's the ether that's
wavy and some people you know there's a
big fight on whether there is something
called an ether out there most people
believe there's no such thing but the
point is there's no such object as a way
wave is a verb it's not a it's not a
noun
okay and they've turned it into a noun
in physics or in mathematics really
second the the wave is 2d each one of
the components the fields are
two-dimensional and there's a problem
with that because you have situations
like the photoelectric effect where
Einstein in fact
showed that the quantum packet is
hitting an electron and taking it out of
its orbit and causing electricity to
flow if you point a light to a shiny
metal plate it emits electricity there's
a current flowing and they're saying
what's hitting it is light and it's
forcing the the electron beads to flow
from one atom to another and that's
current well we had a problem with that
because then if the wave is
2-dimensional how does it interact with
3-dimensional objects so we can't fit
the two-dimensional wave or the
two-dimensional fields in with three
dimensionality interaction that's where
the problem is orthogonality the
electric field goes 90 degrees to the
magnetic field why why would it in fact
when you're in high school or a college
they show you something like this see
loosen it up right they go they go up
and down and they show you a transverse
wave a wave that moves up and down
perpendicular to the direction of travel
right they don't something like that but
there's two conditions first this has to
be tied if this is not tied I can't
produce that that's the first issue so
in order to do this I got a tie one end
on one side and the other one I got to
hold on to then I can shake it this is
not tired I can't do it then why would
the wave travel rectilinear why does
light travel in straight lines you can't
do it with the transverse wave and why
would the electric field travel
perpendicular to the magnetic field is
it just God just that's it and then we
have the problem where does the wave
begin and where does it end here you
have the Andromeda galaxy and you have
an atom emitting a wave to your eye
is it a little boat that travels or is
it an extended object that extends all
the way from there to your eye which is
true which is which is the correct
representation well they like to talk
about packets discrete packets they want
to show you that it's these little balls
that are coming to your eyes that like a
machine gun shooting bullets at you but
that's what they illustrate they
illustrate continues where does it the
way begin does it begin here and end
there how long is a wave where do we
chop it off
see the problem so they talk about
continuous on one side and they talk
about discreteness on the other and
emerged both into the wave packet wave
packet is both discrete and continuous
so again they cover all the bases they
call duality
they say yeah you got accepted it's both
see we can cover every base with this we
got this better than God you know we
cover everything and so what do they end
up with well this is the Penrose wave
packet
this is science here now folks please
don't laugh that's Cupid's arrow and got
tangled with some serpentine in there
this is this is what they illustrate for
the wave back what is a way packet is it
a wave continues waver is it a packet of
this green packet it's both and of
course when they do it that way it's
very hard to challenge so what are we
replacing this was we're saying that
what they've been looking at all these
years is a rope now we can explain all
these features of light why is it
straight because the Rope is pulled
tight and I'll illustrate that here
little rope that I always bring if this
is pulled tight then you can imagine why
there's a straight axis now you can also
see why the electric field which we call
a thread it's a physical object is not a
physical object goes at 90 degrees to
the magnetic field which is again a
thread there's two threads it's it's
what DNA imitated DNA imitated light
that's why we have all these things like
college and they're all extended objects
like a rope they're all rope like
features and here you can see you know
why it's a straight it's pull tight and
how do we produce light well we torque
it there's a torsion it's a
three-dimensional wave not a
two-dimensional up-and-down wave but a
torsion so now you have an atom in fact
I've Illustrated here in the next slide
you have an atom here's the rope now you
know why it's called the Rope hypothesis
by the way and you'll see it here the
two atoms are tied it it binds any two
atoms in the universe and the atoms are
vibrating they they expand and contract
they're little balls of yarn you can
think of it that way one day
and they twist the rope and now you have
a torsion traveling to the other atom
when it akan tracks the same thing see
the good thing about a rope it goes both
ways the signal goes both ways well you
can see me and I can see you at the same
time like that that's because it's a
rope that's connecting these atoms not
something that I send to you and you
send to me see the difference there
there's a difference in the concept here
that that we're trying to show there's
an equation that says C which is the
velocity of light is a constant it
always travels at 300,000 kilometers per
second why well see we'll see you in
other words the velocity of light is
frequency times wavelength that's the F
and that's the lambda there frequency
times line wavelength if you increase
the wavelength you make it longer you
have smaller frequency and if you
increase the the frequency you if you
decrease the frequency you have to have
shorter Wiggly and that's this is the
equation of a rope if you take any rope
right I'm sure you ask real quickly here
I can tighten this many times same
amount of rope and now you have more
links per unit length I can undo this
and you can see what happens now the
lengths the links are longer but you
have fewer links that's frequency times
the wavelength in the model of the rope
this is the equation of a rope that's
why light travels at a constant speed
frequency can only do it at the expense
of wavelength a rope explains this
equation so what's the difference
quantum mechanics talks about discrete
particles and we're saying every atom in
the universe is interconnected they're
all connected to each other now we can
explain gravity for example for example
one thing that quantum mechanics are not
explaining is the force of pull how do
you pull with two particles how does one
particle put a line and others there's
no mediator you have to use angels you
have to use magic and here we're saying
that the atoms are interconnected there
is a rope there that's connecting them
we don't see the rope because you're
talking and you can't see atoms what's
us can you see oh this electromagnetic
rope
we're talking about something so thin
you can't see it besides you wouldn't
need light to see light because that is
light see so people ask why can't we see
it you can't see it this these are
invisible threads are connecting every
atom in the universe and that's the
mechanism the medium through which they
send light they send the torsion signal
okay
we can explain gravity here we see the
Sun the earth and the moon they're all
connected now we can see why the moon
goes around the earth and the earth
around the Sun because they're all
connected why doesn't the moon fly away
never been able to explain this they can
explain with two objects they can say we
have a gravity well this is what
Einstein explained he says we have a
gravity well the sun weighs down the
canvas of space-time we don't know why
it weighs it down because you need
gravity for that but will concede that
okay so the Sun way is that the canvas
down the trampled in the your couch you
know you sit you you sink the the couch
and now the ball rolls around you fine
no problem why do we have third objects
that don't follow that if you look at
Uranus you know it weighs down the
canvas and it has its moon go around it
but it doesn't go around in the same
direction and goes over the poles why
would it do that
Uranus would have to weigh the canvas
sideways then you have the case of Pluto
Pluto has Charon which is it's its moon
and faces the Sun like a bull's-eye
pattern like you're seeing right now for
me then Pluto would have to push the
canvas in my direction for you to see
that that bull's-eye pattern in other
words you can't do it with 3d objects
and they know the mathematicians are
well aware of this problem it's a 2
object system the one that is
unexplained he can't explain three
objects there's no way because you know
you would have to you know make it ad
hoc put it by finger because there's no
other way to explain it you can't
explain it with math for sure
ok so we have a problem there okay so
what do we do with this well we're going
to explain magnetism because I'm going
to show you that show you a different
version of this of what causes these
black hole phenomena I'm saying these
have to do with mass
not with gravity have nothing to do with
gravity according to the threat theory
or the rope hypothesis we take to any
two atoms here right one of the threads
comes loose begin swinging around the
atom we take a row of them we have a
bunch of threads going around each other
now we have a wall of threads going
around now we get explain electricity
and magnetism current is flowing upwards
in here in this vision and the magnetic
field is going sideways we've verified
this in the lab everyday the magnetic
field travels perpendicular to the
electric field well here's a visual
representation of that using the Rope
hypothesis how do we explain magnetism
with this well we have these threads the
ones on the top moving in one direction
in a magnet and the ones on the bottom
move in the opposite direction okay so
you see the flow of all the threads on
the top part of a magnet moving in one
direction and the other ones on the
other side this can explain why if we
throw iron filings over a magnet it
gives you those patterns your gym mat
pattern because something is moving in
that so-called magnetic field I can show
you this here if you put a magnet into
water and you have all these iron
filings floating in there you will see
that over time hopefully you see it
there
it collects all the iron filings if
nothing is moving there it would just
stay you know where they are but
something is moving something is drawing
these iron filings in something is
moving that magnetic field is something
in motion we're saying it's the threads
that are moving and collecting all these
iron filings and keeping them close to
the magnet how does this produce
attraction and repulsion do you have to
explain how a magnet attracts another if
we're gonna explain magnetism well here
we have a vision of that we have two
magnets they're both facing in the same
direction we have north-south
north-south the tip the traditional
north-south north-south and the ones at
the top are all flowing clockwise the
ones on the bottom are flowing
counterclockwise
so what happens as the top ones from the
first magnet come down they collect the
ones from the top of the second magnet
which are coming up so we have this
situation okay and the ones on the
bottom do exactly the opposite and so
now a magnet attracts another magnet and
the closer they are the more threads
that intervene the faster is the
attraction and that's what we verify in
a lab so this is a different mechanism
that what you've been taught in high
school
repulsion we turn the magnet around and
now we have one clockwise the other one
counterclockwise now they're hitting
each other now they don't like each
other on the top and on the bottom so
now you can't put them together the
closer you have the more threads that
intervene the harder it is to push them
together no particles just threads
moving around a magnet how does this
explain now black holes we get explained
now the black hole this is a galaxy when
we factor the magnetic field the
gazillions of threads coming out of
every atom that comprises the magnetic
field a galaxy has gazillions of stars
each one with gazillions of atoms a
bunch of those are excited and they
create the magnetic field of you know
the galaxy so the galaxy has a magnetic
field and each star in it has a magnetic
field also around it so each so you have
these little charged balls in this huge
humongous galaxy and both are charged so
how do we produce now these motions
these these fancy motions if you take a
charged ball in the lab you can do this
in the lab and you can run it through a
magnetic field it turns into it turns in
circles now we can see why you know the
star would go around in circles around
nothing because that ball is going
around nothing we can do this in the lab
we don't need mass we don't need gravity
because it's not a gravitational
phenomenon I'm saying that what's
happening here is you have the magnetic
field of the entire galaxy in this case
it's sweeping through the center
downwards it doesn't matter
different galaxies depending on how you
look at them they could be upside down
whatever is as far as their magnetic
field
and this is the effect you have a field
coming down and it forces a charged
particle you will call it a charge ball
it forces it to go around the circles
around nothing so this is what you would
observe you say ho what's in the center
why does the B go around the flower
because of the mass of the flower no you
know it's a wrong conclusion and the air
I see illustrated here you see the
little starts going around in circles
this is what we would observe through
our telescope we see there's nothing
there all we see is a star going around
yeah because the magnetic field is
invisible we don't see the magnetic
field of the galaxy what they do see
from every galaxy is the Jets they call
them Jets they think it's it's throwing
plasma out of the center again if it's a
if every galaxy has a black hole in the
center it would not be admitting
anything it would be swallowing
everything in you wouldn't see anything
but they had to create the Jets so they
say it's Jets those famous Jets that's
the magnetic field going around the
galaxies and forcing charged objects
such as stars to go around in circles
and sure you you would not see anything
in the center of that you know that
circular motion and here we see a
magnetic field swallowing gases in this
case smoke this is a magnetic generator
and you can see how it's sucking up the
smoke what are the particles that we see
out there in space these gases a star
has suddenly all these gases coming out
of it they say where's it going well it
must be a black hole or an angel
whatever you know it's going in there
somewhere
well we're saying look it doesn't have
to be anything you know you can have in
this case I drew it this way you can
have the gases of a star being sucked
into nothing because it's all drawn by
the magnetic field of the galaxy so you
would not see an object swallowing it
just forces a star to lose the gases off
its surface okay so again all I'm trying
to show you is that there is a different
way to give explanations to these same
phenomena and you surely can't do it
with the black hole because the black
hole has not been defined properly
we don't know how many dimensions that
have we don't know what it's made out of
and we've never seen one directly so
it's an assumption turned into a fact
I'm gonna go now
briefly over dark matter you've heard
you hear about this as much as you hear
about black holes dark matter is the
latest craze what is dark matter here's
a here's our solar system
okay mercury goes real fast around the
Sun Pluto takes with 248 years to go one
time around the Sun very slowly so here
we have this little planet close to the
Sun goes real fast and the one out here
goes very slow if you plotted you know
the speeds of each of the planets around
the Sun the orbits that's the kerb you
would get you can see that as the radius
increases your Batol velocity decreases
okay so the orbital velocity is always
slower the farther you get away from a
planet that's not what happens with a
galaxy it's called the galaxy rotation
problem galaxy has a different curve
this is the one we expect and the one on
the bottom
which resembles the one in our solar
system but that's the one we get the
farther you get the speed is is
increasing or staying the same and they
cannot explain this they say how can
this possibly be how can we get stars on
the outside of a galaxy to travel so
fast that they keep up with the ones on
the inside it's like the whole thing
rotates like a carousel you know the
buggies on the inside as fast as the
course is on the outside they all go at
the same time so to speak there it's not
exactly like that but think of it that
way what explanation you give for this
well they created a theory it's called
the dark kilogram theory the dark
kilogram theory says that you know if
you have to match the observed with a
predicted what you do is you put
kilograms in there and so they put
kilograms wherever they needed it they
said well we need it here if we put it
here in here here then we can explain
this so they created this dark kilogram
theory your card the dark matter I like
the card the dark kilogram because have
you ever seen a kilogram what does it
look like well that's what dark matter
looks like like like a kilogram more or
less so they put this kilogram and say
well if we put it here then we can make
you go faster we don't put it here we
make it goes
so they just fit all this dark matter
wherever they needed it it's an ad hoc
invention they said we can't explain it
we are this is this is what we observe
how do you explain it with math now what
equation can we use for this and so they
invented this variable called dark
matter and so they put it where they
needed to create that curve they need to
just you know explain the curve and they
can't explain it so they said well we're
going to look for it but meanwhile this
is how this is the distribution and if
you look at a galaxy yeah they did it on
the outside usually it's on the outside
of a galaxy the question is why does in
this dark kilogram invisible nonsense
exist between the earth and the moon
don't we have kilograms here as well
dark matter between the earth and the
moon and if we did put it in there then
all the equations would be out of whack
we Newton one word Einstein would work
nothing would work we can't put it
between the Earth and the moon any dark
matter because then you know we wouldn't
we wouldn't be able to use our equations
for for our Rockets or whatever so they
poured it on the outside of a galaxy
it's always on the outside that helps us
explain the curve now they're looking
for it it's invisible it's a translucent
it's dark it doesn't block out any stars
in the in the background but it exists
and we're looking for it and you're
paying for it that's that's important
part I gotta say that this is a web it's
made by a little spider you're on earth
and that's what we're saying that we're
looking at all the stars in a galaxy are
interconnected we're gonna put this web
on top of a galaxy okay so we put it on
top of the galaxy what are we saying
we're saying all the stars are
interconnected now we can see why all
the where the galaxy rotates at the same
time more or less like a carousel
because if every star is interconnected
and on top of that you have the magnetic
field giving more integrity to the
galaxy there you can see how it all
rotates like a carousel we can explain
that part at least we don't need any
Dark Matter for this okay it's a simple
explanation in other words if every atom
in the universe is interconnected then
we can explain why galaxy rotates the
Stars on the outside at the same speed
it to the one on the inside and finally
I'm gonna do a little bit of Big Bang
Big Bang is the moment of creation
without God there's no God here it's
just a self creation and what is the
problem with Big Bang the problem with
Big Bang is that how do you identify the
thing that was there before the
explosion happened what was there you
start out with what before you end up
with with with the universe how do you
create matter from nothing so we all
have a little bit of problem with that
right so they don't answer that question
but then they tell you that all these
universe is that what these little cups
here's the here's the beginning right
and this is time we live in parallel
universes and they're all interconnected
by wormholes those are the little
curlicues you see there they're all
interconnected zero dimensional
entrances one-dimensional wormholes
right let's understand that I do there's
two dimension because I can't draw one
dimensional things yet so these
universes are interconnected by
wormholes the question is what is the
black stuff that separates all these
universe this contains space time and
matter in their space-time and man it's
all in there what's the black stuff that
it gives shape to space-time and to all
these space-time
what is the wormhole traversing to get
to the other universe what is that
medium thought I mean I don't know
that's what they have to answer these
are the questions what physical medium
contours right gives shape the
space-time and how is matter self
created I mean here we don't have God
even even God would have trouble
creating matter but without God I don't
know it's young my imagination so how do
you answer these questions how do you
answer what physical medium contours in
the end and how it's matter self-created
well here we have a couple of
testimonies one is from Hawking again
from his previous history of time it is
impossible to imagine a four-dimensional
space you you can't imagine you just
have to accept that on their word okay
in general relativity it became
meaningless and talk about space and
time outside the limits of the universe
so they're not gonna answer that
question what that black stuff is
because it's meaning it's a meaningless
question they say it's an unscientific
question because they can't prove to you
with an experiment what that black stuff
is but this is a conceptual issue they
can't start their presentation until
they tell me what that black stuff is
because they're going to run wormholes
through it they're going to separate all
these universes from one another with
this whatever thing is it is they have
to tell me what that black stuff isn't
to say that that's beyond the reach of
science it's a saying you know we're not
going to tell you about listen to our
theory you're gonna have to accept it on
the basis of authority questions such as
what is beyond the edge of the universe
or what is the universe expanding into
are as meaningless as asking what is
north of the North Pole
now what is north of the North Pole is
the North Star serious you know or some
star out there there there is a north of
the North Pole what is north of space or
space-time can we imagine you are we
talking about a ball and there's
something out here outside of outside of
our universe and then again what
separates our universe from the other we
have to answer these question we can't
just say well we can't answer that
that's a conceptual issue
and another fella says such questions as
is that universe finite or infinite or
what caused the universe are false
cannot be answered because the point of
view from which such questions arises
does not really exist and is
unattainable in other words that don't
ever answer that question because
creation self creation is beyond words
it's it's got nothing to do with science
how do they we create stuff nothing well
I already give you a little insight
earlier said you know you have
particle/anti-particle
and that's more or less what they how
they explain the creation of something
out of nothing
space is made out of particles anti
particle and particle you separate them
and now you have particles which before
with space you put them together you
create nothing space okay at the Big
Bang itself the universe is thought to
have had zero size rate what was outside
of it we don't know in quantum theory
particles can be created out of energy
in the form of particle/anti-particle
pairs so now we can create energy from
that that means we have something which
is called energy but that just raises
the question where the energy came from
okay look at the explanation the answer
is that the total energy of the universe
is get exactly zero why because we have
positive energy negative energy that's a
mathematical calculation that's minus E
Plus e go zero what does that have to do
with physics they're saying that we have
zero energy that's the starting point
now we separate positive from negative
energy we create matter
we have matter antimatter and now for
some reason we ended up with matter
which is us right and the anti matter
maybe went to another universe I don't
know you see the problem these are all
irrational explanations we're not
attacking the math we're not saying you
know the math is wrong we're saying the
explanations of physical interpretations
they give us the physics part is
absolute erat it's not wrong it's not
incorrect it's irrational they cannot
they they they tell you we have a
Richard Feynman
he's a 1965 Nobel Prize winner and he
says no one understands quantum
mechanics that's what he said 1965 by
that time you know quantum had been
around for
5060 years Arthur Eddington guru of
mathematics of England he said there's
only essentially he said there's only
two people in the universe who
understand general relativity and he was
referring to Einstein and himself so
nobody understands these theories they
can't there's no way they cannot explain
them to you in a rational manner that
you would understand they say you want
to understand it you got to go to
college and learn math then you don't
understand it then you'll then you'll be
brainwashed in the right way
it's nonsense it's all nonsense here's
another testimony this is from Brian
Greene and the fabric of the cosmos
popular documentary he says empty space
is far from empty in fact it is teeming
with activity particles constantly are
popping in and out of existence they
they erupt out of nothingness quickly
annihilate each other and disappear
that's all magic
I caught mathematicians because it's all
magic what is this is this science this
is physics this means that they have the
wrong hypothesis they have the wrong
starting material and they have to cover
for that with these theories these
mechanisms the quantum mechanics empty
space is not that empty another from neo
Susskind it is full of fluctuating
fields full of sorts of jittery things
going on so this is the this is the
establishment version of how particles
get created from the void from nothing
from the vacuum and our particle
particle they separate and you put them
together you create nothing okay well
yeah we do it a little different in
their physics group we say physics base
is synonym of nothing what is nothing
well we have to define it we have to say
space that which has no shape that's
what space is nothing is that which has
no shape so something is that which I
say nothing is that which has no shape
they're in thesis they're when is the
Conte the opposite of the other now we
can use these words consistently now I
can talk to you in a rational manner
when I talk space I'm talking about
nothing when I talk to you about an
object I talk to you about something
that has shape so space cannot
spontaneously acquire length width and
height all by itself and turn into a
physical object and an object cannot
spontaneously lose length with
and become nothing now we can all
understand we can say look here we have
a something and it cannot lose length
width and height suddenly all that
suddenly and spontaneously and become
nothing
you know this becomes this nothing you
can't do that that's magic
that means I'm not gonna explain it to
you I'm not gonna explain to you the
process I'm just gonna tell you it is
and you get accepted and that's what
they're saying
so the conclusion matter has always been
there we've never created the universe
it's never gonna die or or disappear
matter has always been there matter
cannot drift past that which has no
boundaries if space is that which has no
shape there's no boundary to cross not
even God escape that which is not a
medium it has no shape space is the
largest prison never built space is
nothing and we cannot convert something
into nothing nothing into something and
nothing cannot cross that which has no
boundaries now that now we can make
sense of this there is no Big Bang
that's it
you
you